good morning afternoon evening wherever
you are um my name is
a student at Botswana County College
studying business intelligence and data
analytics and uh
let me just go back to the day I
discovered desk as a package for python
uh during my internship which has a
couple of months ago I got tasked with a
very large data file to analyze and for
the first time in my life I ran into a
out of memory error so that was very
unusual because most of my schoolwork
was done with um
as far as that fit comfortably into
memory and I could just load everything
into my data frames my arrays but now
when I started to really uh
get dated with real life data that
superseded my uh computational powers
I ran into some problems then there are
some to do some research on how I could
go around that without necessarily
having to
buy packages staying within the free and
open source community
and it was at that time that uh
a hero rules era's desk
and one of the things I feel disc is
greatly underrated for is how it can
enable
one to perform powerful computations
whilst using what
somebody say it's a lower NPC it kind of
takes away the barriers to entry for
machine learning and data analysis
now I I really don't want to reiterate
on what it is but as you can see Ducks
desk is a flexible
library for parallel computing
and python
this allows us to easily scale out
clusters and handle big data
and uh that was basically how I used it
and one of the most however achieves
this one of the most fascinating about
it is lazy Computing lazy evaluation
when which you only get to call the
variables when you compute them and
therefore you get to manage your memory
better
and the whole memory management
idea is the one that enables for someone
maybe to be writing 16gs of ram like I
do to be able to work on data sets that
all other than that and the second one
is of
chunks clusters basically breaking down
the data
the how do I say data frame but uh the
data into songs that could actually be
scheduled and called when they're needed
and properly indexed instead of just
loading the whole thing then if you
properly index it then you can get the
parts you need when you need them and
you are able to do more with with less
uh I had a very short talk that's about
it thank you